much going on and the largest rockabilly  music festival in the world is back in  our city that's right the orleans is  hosting the viva las vegas four-day  event for its 25th anniversary our  organizers say this year 80 bands are  scheduled to perform along with a big  classic car show burlesque bingo a  vintage fashion show and even dance  lessons fans we spoke to today say they  are thrilled to be back after the  festival was paused for a year and a  half because of the pandemic  it's just all about the experience it's  a very immersive experience i mean you  don't have to but once you come and you  see everybody dressed up it inspires you  to want to  check out our outfit alright doors open  in just about half an hour now we have a  link to tickets on our website along  with the breakdown of all the activities